[Musica]
Buonasera a tutti
Io vi parlerò
dell'effetto tossico dei plastificanti
sulla riproduzione
la riproduzione è alla base della
conservazione della specie quindi è
estremamente importante conoscere quali
possono essere
gli effetti di sostanze inquinanti che
possono alterare questo processo il
processo di riproduzione complesso come
potete vedere dallo schema qui
proiettato Infatti è controllato da un
asse ipotalamo ipofisi gonadi ovvero
delle ghiandole endocrine che producono
degli ormoni questi ormoni
e possono legare dei recettori lungo
l'asse
immaginate un meccanismo chiave
serratura quindi solo l'ormone giusto
può aprire la serratura giusta e
attraverso questo meccanismo controllare
la gonade maschile che produrrà ormoni
maschili maschilinizzanti androgeni
responsabili della produzione degli
spermatozoi la gonade femminile invece
produrrà degli ormoni femminilizzanti
responsabili della maturazione della
cellula uovo che avviene ogni mese nella
donna
un uomo fertile normalmente
produce circa 100 milioni di spermatozoi
questi vengono rilasciati e devono
risalire le vie genitali femminili per
poter fecondare la cellula uovo che è
stata rilasciata a livello delle tube è
un percorso lungo è difficile quindi lo
spermatozoo deve essere di buona qualità
è stimato che circa 200 dei 100 milioni
di spermatozoi sono in grado di svolgere
questo cammino ma solo uno feconderà la
cellula uovo e darà origine allo zigote
e da lì inizierà lo sviluppo embrionale
nel corso del tempo abbiamo osservato
però una riduzione molto significativa
del numero di spermatozoi se noi andiamo
a paragonare il contenuto spermatico di
50 anni fa con oggi Vediamo che oltre il
50% di riduzione è avvenuta è evidente
Inoltre un report della World Health
organization recente del 2021 ha messo
in evidenza che una persona su 6 è
sterile Quand'è che una persona si
ritiene sterile Quando dopo un anno di
rapporti non protetti Non ancora
procreato e questo dato coincide con il
numero Sempre crescente di coppie che
fanno uso di fecondazione medicalmente
assistita Qui abbiamo
l'infertilità è
multifattoriale quindi non siamo in
grado di stabilire esattamente la causa
della
infertilità nella coppia ma di certo
molto importante è il contributo di
sostanze inquinanti soprattutto quelle
sostanze
insegnanti che si comportano come
interferenti endocrini ovvero quelle
sostanze che possono legare il recettore
di ormoni specifici e interferire con il
sistema endocrino che abbiamo visto
prima tra questi troviamo i
plastificanti additivi che vengono
aggiunti alla durante la costruzione
delle plastiche per dare delle
caratteristiche specifiche a queste
durante le fasi di degradazione questi
additivi vengono rilasciati qui vediamo
alcuni esempi degli inftalati il bpa e
come dicevamo Possono aprire questa
serratura e causare una tossicità a
livello riproduttivo
Questi contaminanti li troviamo ovunque
in ogni angolo del globo e quindi è
molto semplice esporsi ad essi in
diversa maniera ci possiamo esporre
attraverso l'inalazione con i tanti
oggetti che abbiamo in casa di plastica
che in questa fase rilasciano nell'aria
queste sostanze lo possiamo fare
attraverso la dieta consumando cibi che
sono ad esempio in delle box di plastica
possiamo esporci attraverso la cute con
l'uso di prodotti per la salute o per la
cura personale o semplicemente
indossando degli abiti
sintetici in alcuni casi l'esposizione
avviene molto precocemente anche durante
l'allattamento infatti nel latte sono
state trovate queste sostanze e noi di
recente Abbiamo trovato anche delle
microplastiche
oppure durante la fase prenatale quindi
un trasferimento dalla mamma al feto
questo è confermato dalla presenza nel
99% delle donne in gravidanza di
sostanze che hanno questo ruolo di
interferenti endocrini non solo il bpa è
presente nel 96% della popolazione
americana ma quello che ci preoccupa
ancora di più e le lavatissimo numero di
composti tossici che noi troviamo
all'interno del sangue prelevato dal
cordone ombelicale
Per chiarire il meccanismo attraverso il
quale queste sostanze possono
interferire con il sistema riproduttivo
noi ricercatori utilizziamo dei modelli
e qui vediamo un esempio di quello che
accade nei nostri laboratori Questo è un
testicolo di zebrafish lo zebrafish è un
piccolo pesciolino che offre il
vantaggio di avere un DNA con una
sintonia altissima con l'uomo quindi è
molto utilizzato negli studi di
tossicologia perché i risultati che
otteniamo possono essere facilmente
traslati all'uomo in questa immagine noi
vediamo
al centro
del
controllo
la presenza di spermatozoi l’
identifichiamo dai loro nuclei che sono
quelli in blu tutte intorno vediamo
delle cellule colorate diversamente
queste cellule sono cellule in via di
maturazione solo cellule germinali che
stanno maturando per diventare
spermatozoi Guardate l'immagine
a fianco e vediamo che l'architettura
testicolare è completamente
alterata quando il nostro piccolo
pesciolino è stato esposto a sostanze
estrogeno simili inquinanti e ambientali
quindi
vediamo non solo una strana
distribuzione delle cellule
germinali in via di maturazione ma anche
una forte riduzione del numero di
spermatozoi
carboidrati i nuclei sono molto meno e
anche questi stranamente distribuiti E
questo ci fanno e questo ci fa pensare
anche a quello che abbiamo detto per
l'uomo questa drammatica riduzione di
spermatozoi nei casi peggiori poi
vediamo che oltre all'alterazione
dell'architettura del testicolo sono
presenti all'interno di essi di esso
anche degli ociti ovvero quelle cellule
che normalmente danno origine alle
cellule uovo quindi abbiamo un fenomeno
di femminilizzazione
questi esperimenti riguardano il pesce
zebra abbiamo detto ma esperimenti
analoghi sono stati fatti anche nei
mammiferi con risultati molto simili
per citare quello che è stato trovato
nella femmina vediamo che c'è una
riduzione del numero degli ociti ma
soprattutto vediamo anche delle
condizioni patologiche come un aumento
della sindrome da ovario policistico
cosa che Notiamo anche nella donna
durante la degradazione delle plastiche
oltre il rilascio dei plastificanti si
generano anche delle micro e delle
nanoplastiche noi ci siamo chiesti
recentemente se queste potessero passare
dai fluidi organici materni al alla
placenta e abbiamo trovato la presenza
di queste di queste microplastiche
ci sono stati ulteriori studi in altri
laboratori in cui sono stati esposti
topi a questo tipo di contaminanti e non
solo hanno ritrovato anche loro il
microplastiche a livello della placenta
Ma addirittura il trasferimento nel feto
con fenomeni di infiammazione molto
importanti
poiché come dicevo è molto difficile non
esporsi a questi contaminanti vista la
loro presenza ovunque
alla ricerca spetta un altro ruolo come
difenderci da essi ed è quello che
stiamo studiando nei nostri laboratori
siamo partiti da un punto importante
questa interferenti endocrini danno
problemi anche al microbiota intestinale
Infatti
animali esposti a questi inquinanti
hanno una disbiosi per cui ci siamo
chiesti se
ripristinando una un microbiota adeguato
quindi utilizzando dei batteri benefici
potevamo risolvere o mitigare questo
problema ed è quello che abbiamo abbiamo
fatto e qui Vi porto ancora una volta un
esempio dei nostri esperimenti dove
potete osservare il controllo l'animale
con una gonale gonade alterata e vediamo
l'interferente endocrino insieme al
probiotico ci riporta ad una condizione
che è molto simile a quella del
controllo Quindi questi risultati sono
estremamente incoraggianti non siamo gli
unici a lavorare su questo altri
laboratori Stanno ottenendo risultati
simili non solo per quanto riguarda la
riproduzione
ma anche per processi più legati a
disturbi metabolici quindi dovremmo
essere sulla buona strada visto la
tematica della serata
Phil de Gap Qual è il GAP che ci
piacerebbe colmare In realtà noi
vorremmo creare un ponte tra la ricerca
scientifica e il cittadino un cittadino
informato sicuramente farà delle scelte
consapevoli E considerando i danni che
possono essere arrecati dall'uso di
plastiche potrebbe scegliere di non far
uso di prodotti
monouso in plastica Oppure potrebbe
essere attento nella lettura delle
etichetta ed evitare
l'acquisto di sostanze che contengono
questi interferenti endocrine la scelta
del consumatore è estremamente
importante e abbiamo la presunzione di
immaginare che questo potrà far avvenire
una transizione tra la chimica attuale
è una chimica verde che sia Attenta ai
prodotti che emette sul mercato
utilizzando tutti quei test
endocrinologici che noi normalmente
utilizziamo nei nostri laboratori
concludo Con l'augurio che
soprattutto i giovani ricercatori ce ne
sono molti qui in mezzo a noi anche i
miei collaboratori che ringrazio per
aver contribuito a questa presentazione
continuino a
ad essere ispirati che è uno dei temi
del Ted no ispirarsi e
diffondere nel mondo la conoscenza e
ovviamente the dexe è un ottimo modo per
farlo Grazie per l'attenzione Grazie
[Applauso]